I play a lot of video games on the
program and a little segment we call
clueless gamer okay start it out started
out as kind of a joke and then it took
off yeah
well over the years I've gotten to play
with some really cool people just last
night and it's gonna air tomorrow but
just last night I had the chance to play
the highly highly anticipated Assassin's
Creed origins with one of the greats in
the NFL Green Bay Packers quarterback
Aaron Rodgers okay yeah we played
Assassin's Creed origins now as you all
know he was just sidelined with a pretty
bad injury okay and he had to have
surgery everything but he postponed he's
supposed to get surgery for his arm he
postponed his surgery cuz he wanted to
play video games with me
Wow yeah yes and they told him they told
him by doing that he's threatening his
career and he said I don't care
Wow Conan and this video game mean more
to me than my future in the National
Football League
that's a quote Wow maybe okay anyway
maybe yeah does that seems like a bad
idea yeah anyway here's a quick preview
just a tiny preview of what you'll see
you tomorrow night walk us through what
happened I know we've all seen the team
but I want to make you relive this yeah
I roll that to my right I threw the ball
and I got tackled and kind of slammed on
the ground but I'm good now 13 screws
later and Here I am uh 13 screws later
right
[Laughter]
always got to know wow come on oh okay
now I'm just weeding a lot of hippos are
folks gather together there we go
doesn't he know forward oh oh I want to
drive there you go I thought there was a
driver brother people over if this was
LA he'd be Armenian alright here we go
should I try and hit people yeah sorry
sorry Barney coming through
oh I kneeled that guy can this be the
whole game this
I'm sorry horses okay a lot of fun stuff
happens to take it out tomorrow
you